What age are you now?
I'm 18 now.
18! You're driving a car?
Yeah, I've just been driving for like five months now, yeah.
Really? Where did you go?
Where did you go?
I mean, do you drive? Do you do road trips and stuff?
Yeah, I do.
I've done a few of them, yeah.
I just got an ice cream van.
What the hell is wrong with you?
You know what? Are these ice cream fans?
Why did you get an ice cream van?
Is that in case the, you know?
When I was younger, I always wanted to be an ice cream man.
Right.
I've always had interest in that sort of career.
So, I don't know.
The ice cream side of show business.
Yeah!
It's really cool.
Do you have ice cream in it?
Do you stock?
Fully stocked, yeah. I've got sweets.
Do you stop, play the tune, stop, and then sell the ice cream to the children?
No I don't sell it, yeah.
You just give it away?
No, no, I don't even serve yet...
...because I think you have to get a license.
It's quite complicated.
So, I just play the tune.
You play the tune and innocent children think, "It's an ice cream man!"
And you drive on by?
Do you realize the effect of this?
The child sees the ice cream man; he hears the thing, "Ice cream man! Ice cream man!",...
...runs out...
...it's the ice cream man! "Ron Weasley is driving the damn ice cream truck!"
And it doesn't stop!
Then the kid goes back and goes, "Mom, mom! I saw Ron Weasley driving an ice cream truck!"
And he gets sent to a child psychiatrist.